When a table invokes
the cellForRowAtIndexPath method,
it passes the control
object in index path.
An index path is a struct
that holds the row number.
In order to populate our table cells,
there are a few steps we need
to perform in this method.
The first step is to dequeue
a reusable cell from the table,
using the correct reuse identified.
The second step is to find the model
object that corresponds to the row
in question.
The third step is to set the images and
labels in the cell,
using the data from the model object.
And last but not least, return the cell.
For the favorite things app,
we'll use a standard TableViewCell.
It comes with a UI label
property named textlabel.
And our reuse identifier
will be FavoriteThingCell.
Here are three different implementations
of cellForRowAtIndexPath.
Which of these three accomplishes all
four of the steps previously outlined?
To try out the different methods,
check out this branch.